non-minimalists
that is such a good point it makes me
think of this stat about
jen i think it's jen's ears they're
having the least amount of
sex than any other and it has to be the
least amount of sex of any generation
lowest teen pregnancy of any generation
yeah
part of that sounds good but then my
guess is it might be for the wrong
reasons though right
it's not good it's part of what you saw
now i'm watching the social dilemma
tonight
okay um my neighbors and i are all
getting together because we think this
is a good conversation piece where you
should watch it and then sit
and talk about it afterwards so we're
getting together to watch this um
it's about what your what your reason is
now i have a lot of young girls that
have told me they've had one sexual
experience that scared them and now
they're not having sex at all that's the
gen xers
and that's from the young guys at 10
watching porn and thinking it's okay to
choke a girl the first time they have
sex with her and she's like
what just happened here i'm never doing
this again their
phones are more important to them than
their vehicles like there was a survey
last year
would you rather have your parents take
your car away for a year or your phone
every kid shows their phone because they
can use their phone to get an uber
right right they don't want the
responsibility of the car yeah the same
thing is going on with communication
they can talk with their friends here
but why bother it's so much work to meet
in person
and to meet in person means then you
have to try then you have to engage then
you have to try and like make that move
to hook up
the no sex thing i think is very
unhealthy yeah yeah
and to me like when i say it sounds good
and that's because we're in a rather
moralizing culture right that
that puts a premium on and by the way we
even use
weird language around it i took her
virginity
really what did you do with it can you
give it can i give it to someone else
yeah she was a willing participant yeah
she shared it with you
right and by the way yeah now that she
doesn't have it what what
am i able to do something with with it
like we we use this language
without even realizing like that's a
very normal thing for us to use but it
should be abnormal the way that we
the way that we talk about sex is often
guilty or shameful and we even have a
question about that
in a little bit but before we get to our
audience questions let's let's make this
sort of case against porn in the case
for porn because i think you're the
perfect person to talk about both
because
we see that it's hurt tim's life here
and it's hurt a lot of people's lives
probably because of early exposure there
are probably other reasons as well
but also it exploits certain that in
that industry can
exploit a certain number of people as
well so maybe let's talk about the bad
side and maybe we'll talk about the
potential upsides of it
the bad side so you know when i started
shooting in the early 90s there really
wasn't a
bad side yet as a female performers you
were kind of
praised catered to craft services called
you the day before what do you want
you were treated like gold because not a
lot of women wanted to do this right
so you were still treated like we don't
want her to run off and like move back
home
it wasn't jenna jameson didn't arise yet
this didn't become
mtv-ish pop culture-ish so we were
celebrated even
how the man disrobed you on set had to
be very sensual
and soft and no rush it was then illegal
to do choking and smacking
and anything rough the girl always had
to look equally in control by law
to be able to distribute this type of
content so because the laws were right
here we had no internet
everybody stayed on board and it was
this really kind of
everything was sensual and sexual and it
was a bunch of really sexual beings
in the industry from in front of the
camera to behind the camera and then
came the internet
and the realization that we need tags we
need different tags so when people put
in keywords
now we have these tags so now we have to
do these 10 extra things
in this movie and it just became a thing
and not um a beautiful substance of
sharing you could learn
something from a porn in the 90s that
was intimate the caressing i mean there
was like
30 minutes of caressing and foreplay
back then
because the sex was so much shorter and
they didn't show full penetration
so they had to fill that time the angles
were from the side i mean
and it was this thing and then here
comes the internet here comes gonzo and
it's like we got to get this much in in
23
24 minutes and we got to cover all these
categories
now we removed the sexual element of it
and made it a total business that would
cater to
keywords how is that sexual so the
downside with that is that
and then the industry affects the weak
when it comes to talent
so the downsides that i saw of men that
would hire men that would go into malls
by high school
and find 18 year old girls and say do
you want to make twenty thousand dollars
a month and of course
the girl that watches the kardashians
every day and everything i need channels
she wants to make twenty thousand
dollars a month she wants to get her
hair done
buy clothes you know she knows exactly
so the luring
in of the uneducated to sign paperwork
that then
kind of gives away a lot of their rights
and them being so afraid to say no to
the money
they start making sexual choices and i
always told everyone never do something
on camera
for your first time so if you haven't
been with a girl
on in your personal life why would you
do a girl girl scene on camera
you